bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
40 ans de saint quentin en yvelines
consacrée à la culture comment le
domaine culturel at il évolué qu'en 40
ans quels sont les enjeux aujourd'hui
quels seront les enjeux demain pour en
parler trois invités jacques bourdon
bonjour jours le directeur du théâtre de
50 ans divine de la scène nationale et
donc voilà keaton est démontré très
important de la culture sur le
territoire et ricarda bonjour aux jouets
libraire vous êtes directeur des
librairies du pavé et vous êtes un
historique de la culture sur le
territoire puisque vous avez connu ou
frôlé les 40 ans des votes d'évolution
et puis robert cadalbert vous êtes le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et c'est vrai
que j'allais presque dire au départ 50
anodine de la culture c'est presque un
pléonasme on revoit tout ça mais on va
commencer d'abord par la partie
historique donc les premières années
erykah badu peut-être commencé avec vous
parce que c'est vrai que vous avez connu
le territoire dès ses débuts si je puis
dire oui oui tout à fait dès l'origine
de la vie de nouvelles et même un peu
avant puisque en effet la notion même
d'animation
dans la vie nouvelle a été développée à
partir d'un colloque qui s'est tenu à
avignon un post 68 où s'invitent à tout
à fait tout à fait où le couple central
des villes nouvelles s'est très
rapidement posé la question de
l'implantation de groupes de près
animations puisque c'était avant tout
équipement dans des champs
sur ce territoire avec l'idée que voilà
la culture ça doit pas être éloignée de
la population qui la population est
aussi actrice de la culture
oui enfin y avait une question quand
même d'accueil des nouveaux habitants on
partait de rien je pense que en fonction
des interlocuteurs il y avait des les
arrière pensées différents 1 et que
l'établissement public de saint quentin
comme les autres établissements publics
où que ce soit le groupe central des
villes nouvelles en mettant en place des
équipes culturelle sur les différentes
villes nouvelles avait pour objet quand
même de provoquer en quelque sorte des
élus et de créer quand même les
réversible au niveau de la ville
nouvelle et d'accueillir les nouveaux
habitants alors vous êtes dans leur
dimension culturelle fondateur de là
parce qu l'association pour la promotion
des activités socioculturelles le liens
socioculturels il existe des importants
ne dépas oui dès le départ c'était
relativement
important puisque d'abord ya donc un
groupe d'animateurs qui a été mis en
place surtout des musiciens des
comédiens des spécialistes de la vidéo
qui à cette époque light est extrêmement
embryonnaires qui ont été mis en place
s'appelait le groupe organon organon
c'est un organe non qu'est donc été
installé par donc le court central des
villes nouvel établissement public pour
l'accueil des nouveaux habitants et
développer des premières activités
culturelles avec notamment une
programmation autour de cause ils nous
avaient lieu
et avec avec un peu d'auto gestion
s'est posé en effet la question de
l'accueil des nouveaux habitants et puis
de ce qui existait il existait quand
même des fédérations et des mouvements
d'éducation populaire on était quand
même dans un mouvement post soixante
huitarde où l'on pensé qu' on allait
pouvoir changer la ville changer la vie
et que les mouvements d'éducation
populaire soit les mjc les francs et
franches camarades la folle ou autres
étaient des mouvements
assez implanté sur la ville nouvelle et
dont l'issue sont issus d'ailleurs
beaucoup de responsables politiques
oui c'est vrai qu'à la ligue est aussi
un lien entre la politique et la culture
dès le début il ya aussi cette idée
peut-être que dans un territoire qui n'a
pas d'histoire la culture peut pas en
tenir lieu c'est fondamental nous sommes
tous des immigrés à sa grille en
yvelines à 95% nous sommes tous des
immigrés et donc il fallait absolument
créer du lien tissé du du lien et c'est
vrai que la culture la vie associative
allant entre le social le socioculturel
gondi et la culture il n'y a pas de
frontières très très fermé mais en tous
les cas pour nous ce qui était important
c'est que les gens qui arrivaient qui
connaissait rien bas soit accueilli
rencontrent leurs voisins on a eu un
phénomène énorme c'était effectivement
le carnaval des ténèbres il allait
réveiller les voisins or en faisant la
fête tous âges et l esprit de faisons en
sorte que les gens se connaissent et
avant que leur propre culture leur
propre histoire on ce lien social
un mot peut-être sur ce carnaval des
ténèbres c'était
c'est la mémoire collective je pense que
tout le monde en parle karl des ténèbres
a été un grand grand succès d'abord pour
l'implantation du théâtre de l'unité qui
était à l'initiative
ça faisait partie donc également de la
politique de là parce qu'à l'époque et
puis également la vie associative
extrêmement intense un robert le disait
mais c'est vrai que la structuration de
la vie associative a été extrêmement
important moi personnellement j'ai créé
en l'espace de trois ans j'ai créé aider
à créer 80 associations
donc au niveau 7 a tué ses nouveaux
habitants qu'on accueillait ont commencé
par des choses extrêmement simple sur
l'organisation de la vie locale la vie
dans les logements ou accession à la
propriété ou locatif on permettait aux
gens de se rencontrer d'abord d'échangés
la perceuse d'échanger des services et
puis peu à peu la vie se structuraient
les besoins augmentent et et bien sûr
derrière ça il y avait quand même la
culture la culture qui émergeait donc le
carnaval des ténèbres a été un moment
très très fort et eu son succès pas
parce que c'est des professionnels qui
ont implanté le carnaval mais parce que
le carnaval a été pris en charge par la
vie associative locale à lait qu' il y
avait des concours de bande pour le
carnaval il y avait dans tous les
quartiers d une prise en charge
par la vie associative jacques bordé oh
par après plus plus plus concrètement
des lieux culturels notamment et
notamment du théâtre de 50 ha mais est
ce que quand vous êtes arrivé ici cette
sorte comme ça d'ébullition prise en
main par les habitants de la culture
vous l'avez sorti ou c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est très différent au fond
de ce que vous faites vous dans un état
stationnaire est encore très présent et
c'est ça que je trouve formidable en
arrivant et j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
notamment roland nadeau j'avais
rencontré ce moment là tu me racontes un
petit soir de la ville qui est le
prédécesseur de robert cadalbert et je
lui ai dit je ressens ici quelque chose
de l'utopie dès la création des maisons
de la culture et pourquoi parce que la
première réunion à laquelle j'ai assisté
en tant que directeur de la scène
nationale avec des spectateurs c'était
avec les relais et j'ai rencontré des
relais alors que t as tu existes depuis
93 qui me disait on est relais depuis 20
ans depuis 25 ans pourquoi parce qu'ils
étaient relais à la parce qu'ils étaient
relais au pollen qui ensuite fait la
préfiguration est devenue scène
nationale donc il y avait il ya une
continuité humaine une continuité
militante on va venir et on a encore
aujourd'hui des relais au théâtre qui
sont plus les antennes qui qui
réunissent des abonnés autour d'eux et
c'est à peu près 1500 abonnés a eu tout
seul c'est 100 personnes là qui sont
issus de cette histoire là donc il ya un
vrai bien et moi ça m'a frappé beaucoup
vous êtes ici donc vraiment les foules
dans sa culture donc oui entre
l'histoire de la ville est loin et cette
fondation autour d'un projet culturel et
puis les bâtiments parce que certains
opposent dizois maintenance et des
bâtiments c'est il ya des réalisations
comme ça très très spectaculaire et
c'est plus l'histoire ancienne et en
fait non il ya un vrai bien une vraie
histoire et on continue moi je trouve
que cette ville continue de se nourrir
de son de son projet culturel initial
avec évidemment tous les équipements
culturels qui existent partout les
médiathèques parlera peut-être novembre
à la télé c'est à dire avant il ya eu
une volonté politique très forte
oui de créer que le voir chaque lieu est
son lieu culturel c'est du côté
de
la culture est une compétence partagée
entre les communes et l'agglomération et
joue à d'autres villes nouvelles france
parti et cergy nous on appris la culture
comme étant une mission partagée et on a
créé par réseau des médiathèques qui est
assez exceptionnel même si ils évoluent
tous tous les jours et ce réseau de
médiathèques on a voulu qu'il ya une
médiathèque dans chaque commune et cet
objectif de faire des équipements bien
sûr la politique ne sait pas qu une
politique d'équipement mais elle est
quand même importante si on veut que
cette vie associative cette vie
culturelle puis les gens puissent se
rencontrer se nourrir de la connaissance
de tous ces gens là il faut quand même
des lieux et donc depuis le départ avec
rolande ado on a effectivement créé ce
réseau médiathèque une maison de la
poésie
huit salles de spectacles dont la scène
nationale il ya d'autres
donc on a effectivement investis dans la
culture faisons très très très
importante mais jusque là il ya quand
même une question de dépossession par
les institutions par la politique
l'effet de la culture je crois que là il
ya maldonne au départ c'est à dire que
quand la question que s'est posée
c'était de dire est ce qu'on peut faire
l'animation et concevoir la culture dans
une ville nouvelle où on parle
strictement rien de champ par rapport à
une ville traditionnelle qui a une
histoire cas des équipes mais ce qu'on
peut faire une autre culture offrant
donc on était vraiment dingue ou vance
de mai 68 1 et de se dire la ville
nouvelle c'est un terrain
d'expérimentation sociale extrêmement
importante et innovantes et les choses
ont changé avec le temps et qu'au départ
les gens qui arrivent et été vécu comme
des contre pouvoirs par les élus en
place et d'ailleurs n'y a qu'à regarder
toute la classe politique a suivi
en ado serein beau robert et autres et
les élus des villes nouvelles sont issus
de cette vie associative sont issus de
cette vie associative et on a pensé
qu'on pouvait en effet traiter la
culture autrement que par les lignes
budgétaires habituel et institutionnels
les logiques des mjc les logiques de
maison de la culture avec les lignes de
fait vous avez l'impression d'avoir
accepté pour céder un peu de ça oui je
pense qu'à un moment donné ou un effet
vous le regrettez ou pendant une
institutionnalisation de la culture et
par des politiques de ministères alors
que justement là parce qu était une
espèce d'idée de se dire allez on va
supprimer toutes les lignes budgétaires
affectés à la culture aux socio culturel
social etc on va mettre tout ça dans un
melting-pot un gros pot qui était le là
parce qu un et à l'intérieur de ça les
associations les élus et les structures
mouvement d'éducation populaire va se
débrouiller pour faire quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et au bout d'un certain
temps et ben les élus les communes ont
repris un lent comme dans une ville
traditionnelle la politique d'animation
la politique culturelle et ont mis en
place des équipements avec des logiques
d'équipement alors alors qu'au départ on
va en parler on va parler dans la
deuxième partie justement de la mise en
place de ces équipes aux médias il ya un
groupe qui fait un peu le lien entre ce
que vous disiez peut-être
d'institutionnalisation ces deux groupes
black blanc beur qui a débuté ici à
saint quentin et je vous propose de
regarder un sujet sur les 3 b qu'on vous
dit black blanc beur à la merise
bonjour météo b3 alors nous commençons
par l'anticyclone qui débutent le jeudi
soir vendredi
quelques éclaircies sur le littoral
nous passons à samedi où
you les baies 3 entendez black blanc
beur on le hip hop au beau fixe avec rat
petit pas leur dernier spectacle en date
dont la première représentation aura
lieu jeudi prochain ils reviennent en
force chez eux à trappes après dix ans
de tournée avec une dernière apparition
très remarquée en afrique du sud c'est
en tenue décontractée survêt collant
basket et foulard qui répétait cette
semaine à la merise l'occasion à la
pause de s'offrir une petite visite
guidée des coulisses café en main et de
découvrir les autres b3 on y va
les costumières safer dernier point de
couture avant de donner aux danseurs
leurs tenues de scène tout le monde est
sur le pont et le stress monte surtout
pour claeys le petit dernier de la
troupe et je m'étais vraiment comment on
peut dire la patate quoi on va pas c'est
donc la deuxième partie de cette
émission c'est à dire ce qui s'est
construit dans l'est dans les années 90
du rêve à la réalité
alors 1993 et la construction du terme
de saint quentin en yvelines ça c'était
un énorme chantier évidemment c'était
une décision importante est
effectivement pour nous d'avoir la scène
nationale dans un équipement phare au
centre de saint quentin en yvelines
puisque nous a voulu que dans 62 50
animiez à la fois bien sûr du commerce
comme ailleurs mais on voulait de la
culture vous voulez l'université on
voulait de l'emploi de la mixité de
toutes les fonctions pour faire et dans
les fonctions d'abord la culture au
coeur de 50 minutes avec ce théâtre de
saint quentin aisne qui est le phare
effritement de la culture japon dont
pour les gens qui savent pas qu est-ce
qu est-ce que c'est une scène nationale
une scène nationale c'est un équipement
qui a une vocation à présenter des
créations migration d'envergure
nationale internationale à faire un
travail aussi de diffusion de et de
circulation des oeuvres est aussi et ça
c'est moins connu ça rejoint peut-être
les questions de l'utopie et du rapport
avec la création et la culture d'un
travail d'éducation et de formation le
plus large possible d'ouverture à des
nombreux big ce que vous faites ce qu'on
essaie de développer aux mairies comme
et ça c'est quelque chose d'important
parce que je pense que ça en partie
c'est là que vous êtes l'héritier répond
pas complètement mais en partie je pense
que les uns les autres que ce soit aux
prises que ce soit à la ct que ce soit
au bel ébat que ce soit la scène
nationale on y rit d'une certaine
manière vous avez entre guillemets perdu
peut être un contrôle sur les choses
mais vous avez gagné c'est à dire
qu'effectivement la culture il n'y a pas
de ville franchement boîtier un peu
bourlingué il n'y a pas de ville il ya
quoi 140 mille habitants blissy cent
cinquante 150 maintenant il n'ya pas de
ville de 150000 habitants en france qui
au cas aucune ville nouvelle ça c'est
sûr et pas de ville je crois qu'ils un
équipement de ce niveau là petits moyens
et grands de saleté qui servent aussi
bien la vie associative qu'à la vie
culturelle un très haut niveau avec une
programmation d'une richesse absolument
incroyable et qui fonctionne pas ce
qu'est ce qu'on voit trop bas et non
parce qu'a priori ça fonctionne le temps
c'est un problème qu'on peut se poser
non ça fonctionne on a le tir de saint
quentin il est on en train d'exploser en
ce moment la fréquentation mais les
autres lieux marche très bien aussi et
une maison de la poésie il y en a pas
deux en ile de france il ya la maison de
poésie à paris et celle de saint quentin
en yvelines le réseau de médiathèques
franchement c'est unique en france avoir
un réseau comme celui là où les gens
peuvent emprunter des livres les rendre
la ville d'à côté et c'est toute
l'activité qui tourne qui tourne autour
non c'est vraiment une ville qui est
bâti sur un projet culturel et qui
continue d'exister après on essaie
d'inventer c'est une responsabilité pour
d'oeuvre
c'est une responsabilité énorme parce
que justement les lieux de culture avec
peut-être les lieux sportifs mais
peut-être d'une façon encore plus large
sont les seuls endroits où tout le monde
se retrouve au moment du partage du
spectacle et on fait tous franchement on
n'est pas que dans la consommation on
est tous dans les rencontres avec des
artistes dans les ateliers dans la danse
dans toute une vie autour qui ce qui ce
qui se dira au loto et donc ce sont des
lieux de vie qui sont partagés où on a
vraiment toutes les classes sociales les
origines et c est le travail qu'on fait
permet justement de cette mixité se
mélangent là et ça je pense que ça joue
un rôle très important dans l'idée dans
l'identité de la ville est dense on est
dans son devenir aux fouilles il ya un
festival absolument formidable 5 est
aussi fondateur c'est le festival la
tour prend l'air et je vous propose de
regarder un sujet c'est justement ce
festival la tour prend l'air la tour a
bien pris l'air ce week-end à voisins le
bretonneux à l'occasion du 4e festival
lancé par l'association compte chat prod
un festival tout musique emmené par le
groupe qui monte qui monte les mass
hysteria et leur furie métal
communicative nourri dès l'enfance par
la mano negra et noir désir
c'est ce qu'on veut faire passer c'est
cultiver vous c'est profiter de la vie
vive les bons
souvent le peu de bons moments qu'on
allait vivre vraiment en ses membres
le festival n'aime pas les étiquettes et
le prouvent sanseverino l'archétype le
swing délicieux des chansons à textes de
l'esprit rien que de l'esprit
c'était le bon temps
les films d'horreur les figurants
mort de rire lag
aujourd'hui tout le cacheton
pour ceux qui tombent tout comme maurice
dupont
le message de conches à prod c'est
restons ouverts mais restons conscients
gardons les idées claires il ya des
choses à faire on les a pas sans rien
donc il faut être présent sur le terrain
au quotidien et se battre c'est un
combat permanent le festival aura reçu
durant ces deux jours 2800 spectateurs
c'est plus du double de l'an dernier et
accueilli quinze groupes à terme
l'objectif de l'association créer une
salle pour les musiques actuelles
dernier plaisir musical avec bénabar
c'est l'histoire d'une fille
généralement d abriter préconçues ton
père a crié mais il s'est tapé ma vie ce
petit col
des ares mais il était encore furieux
les plus d'émasculer pourtant sérieuse
large et 3 falga
inattendu chaque dessin animé mois
m
troisième partie donc et demain et
return à bord d un problème que j'avais
commencé un petit peu abordé la
multiplicité des lieux elle existe mais
c'est vrai qu'on est dans une période
financièrement économiquement difficile
est ce que on a sept boyen pour fuir
vivre tous ces vieux que le tirait par
rapport à la demande et en particulier
des responsables d'équipement
certainement pas mais je voudrais plus à
oui mais c'est vrai que rick a raison
même s'il garde un peu sur une utopie de
dépeindre 2 et là on a faim oui c'est le
monde qu'il a pas vieilli et que saint
quentin est encore jeune pendant
longtemps donc
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai problème
c'est une question qu'on se pose depuis
maintenant 4 5 ans va sont assidus et la
réponse que l'on a tendance à dire c'est
plus de travail en commun plus de
mutualisation des complémentarités dans
les programmations afin que
effectivement les spectacles tournent la
création se fasse avec justement avec
cette vie associative qui demande que ça
un même si malheureusement dans notre
société on devient de plus en plus ont
obligé des consommateurs plutôt acteurs
de la ville en tous les cas la culture à
saint quentin devine ce réseau
d'équipements très lourd parce que on
aurait pu rajouter à la maison de la
poésie le musée de la ville on est aussi
un des rares à avoir un musée aussi
performant la maison de l'environnement
des sciences développement il a
travaillé avec les écoles
wiki qui à présent qui fait tout ce ce
lien bon effectivement est ce qu'on
pourra continuer à tenir le coup parce
que c'est des charlots ressent
aujourd'hui on pousse à mutualiser plus
dans tout en gardant les identités de
chacun et qu'effectivement c'est du
lourd la culture soit bien une charge
partagée entre les communes et
l'admiration jacques pendant vous avez
beaucoup de bien avec les directeurs d
des salles du terrible bien sûr parce
qu'il ya des projets qu'on partage des
projets d'accueil de spectacles ou de
création et puis la saison jeune public
qui est qui et partager tous les lieux
de l'agglomération qu'on présente
ensemble chaque année et qui là aussi on
peut on peut se féliciter est unique en
son genre en france une offre de
spectacles qui permet de
le satisfaire les tout petits gamins
jusqu'à jusqu'aux adolescents avec des
créations avec de la danse du théâtre de
la musique et justement tout un projet
partagé de d'action éducative
extrêmement intense saint quentin en
yvelines ça c'est peu mais elle est le
champion de 2 du travail en terme
d'action culturelle dans tous les
domaines y compris l'opéra avec des
résultats a été rétabli tout à fait
spectaculaire et constant et chaque lieu
alors moi je vous parle il explique ça
je peux parler de ce qu'on fait dans
l'autre théâtre mais chaque année on
fait trois ou quatre projets avec des
amateurs et cd projet au long cours
c'est pas simplement une rencontre comme
ça c'est des gens qui travaillent toute
l'année des gens qui s'abonnent qui
viennent avec les enfants les parents et
donc mais c'est toute une moi je pense
que c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est l'héritage aussi de la
situation et de l'esprit de la fondation
de cette ville qui fait que c'est pas
simplement d équipements d incarner mais
qu'au contraire il ya d'autres manières
de s'est approprié quand on fait des
projets avec des amateurs on mélange des
adultes des enfants originaires de
différents endroits de l'agglomération
de différents milieux sociaux d'une
certaine manière on essaye alors
évidemment on n'y arrive pas toujours
aussi bien que ce qui pouvait exister ou
parfois mieux ça dépend des fois mais on
réinvente je trouve cette dimension là
et puis il ya une autre chose qui est
paradoxal dans la société dans laquelle
on est aujourd'hui depuis 2008 on va
venir on peut le basé sur la crise on a
une montée en puissance et alors ça on
le retrouve au niveau de la région
parisienne est d'ailleurs d'aider du
besoin de culture enfin moi je dis il ya
une femme culture et humblement 14 ans
d'abord c'est vrai la débitante est
effectivement financière a programmé ce
congrès il ya en même temps une
augmentation de la fréquentation qui est
très important mais vraiment
significative et ça c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant parce que ça montre aussi
que dans les périodes de d'incertitude
dans lesquelles
celle qu'on traverse est quand même
assez sérieuse depuis la haye est une
sorte de refuge c'est un refuge ou un
besoin d'une nourriture et d'une
certaine manière je trouve qu'on
rencontre notamment d'en discuter avec
les spectateurs où les rencontres
artistes spectateurs et terrain on
retrouve certains questionnements des de
la période 2 qui a vu la fondation de
cette de cette ville nouvelle et je
pense que là aussi du point de vue des
idées et pourquoi pas des utopies il ya
des choses qui qui demande à être
inventer encore pas encore inventé voilà
malgré à l'institutionnalisation un mot
pour conclure robert cadalbert eskimos
quelque chose encore sur le plan
culturel sur le territoire ont
certainement avec toutes les utopies et
les rêves qui sont on doit mais pour moi
cette culture ça s'invente ensemble c
c'est le socle vivant on parle souvent
de développement durable trois piliers
le développement économique
environnement la sauvegarder mais la
culture c'est bien c'est pas un autre
plié c'est le centre qui réunit tous
parce que est présente partout la
culture même c'est ce qui reste quand il
n'y a plus rien absolument on va rester
sur ce beau de deux conclusions merci
infiniment à tous les trois voilà cette
émission consacrée à la culture est
terminée mais nous serons de retour très
bientôt pour une autre émission
consacrée aux 40 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines